No audio. Thank you, Marcos.
After a flying start.
Alright. Let me start that again.
So welcome to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm David Flanagan, blah blah blah, also known
as Rawkode. This is the first cluster that
we've had in quite a while. So I'm
really excited to be back. We've got lots
of clusters planned over the next twelve weeks.
And today is a good special one to
kick us back off because we've got two
people who have previously participated
in clustered,
and it's gonna be a whole lot of
fun. So lots of hellos in the chat,
I'll get to them in just a minute.
But before we do that, I wanna just
say thank you to our sponsors that help
make Clustered happen.
So first and foremost, Teleport. Teleport is a
product that we have been using on Clustered
since the very first episode, and they've been
supporting this channel for the last few months,
and I can't thank them enough. Teleport is
a great product. We use it every single
week to fix these broken clusters, and I
recommend that you all go check it out
at the link below.
There. I've never done that before.
I also wanna thank Equinix Metal. They were
my previous employer and, you know, it was
great having access to bare metal, but Equinix
have very generously decided to continue supporting cluster
by providing all the bare metal clusters, all
the bare metal machines for me to install
a cluster onto. So thank you very much
Equinix Medal, always a pleasure.
Alrighty. Let's say hello to our wonderful guests
for today.
Hello,
Russell. Hello, Marek. How are you both?
Hey. How are you doing? Good. Just just
got my break in on time. Well, I've
already broken the show by muting myself at
the start. So, you know, at least the
first thing that went wrong was me, as
always.
Can we start with a little bit of
an introduction? We'll start with you, Russell.
Hi. I'm Russell. I'm
in Rawkode's Discord quite a lot. I
I don't work in tech anymore, so I'm
not gonna promote anything or try to recruit
anybody. Just
just have fun.
Alright. Thank you very much.
Mark?
My name is Mark.
I've worked with Kubernetes for a little while.
Did a lot with actually, like, the control
plane stuff. And, I've been trying to share
my knowledge, with some educational
content here on YouTube. And,
yeah, I'm excited to
excited to get into this cluster and see
how it's broken.
I'm sure they're not broken too badly. Right?
You've both been very kind to each other
as those sparks fell up your face.
You can always tell how devious someone's been
by that smirk, that smile that comes on
their faces, we're about to get started.
All right, lots of lows. Hello everybody.
Let's get onto our first cluster. So before
we get started, Marek, you offered to be
the first fixer.
So I'm gonna pop up my screen share.
I've set the timer to forty six minutes,
so that's one minute for us to get
things going.
So I'm gonna open a session on the
Russell control plan.
And if you can join a session, please
remember not to open a new one and
start exporting your KubeConfig,
and then we'll take it from there. So
best of luck.
Okay. One second.
How do I join that session? It's not
letting me.
It's not letting you?
So I don't I was gonna flash my
IP address, but I guess it doesn't really
matter, does it?
If you go to
activity
and then click on active sessions, there should
be a join button next to my IP
address and stuff. Yep. Yep. Sorry. My bad.
I forgot.
Alright. Hey. You're in. You're in. Let's
let's get started with setting up our kubectl
here.
Let's see.
So oh, we have a story. I have
heard that the stories are legendary, so we're
gonna check that out.
Let's see. We have oh, chapters. My goodness.
Are these hints or are these the story
we should be following along, Russell? What what
do want us to do?
I'm
surprised. Welcome to the Shire still. Think that
might be empty, but yeah. So
do do what you want, but as soon
as you find a problem, maybe go into
chapter one and have a look. Alright. So
let let's let's check for our control plan
first, Mark. Right?
Yeah. Okay. So the
let's get the let's export our cube config,
which I think our kube config
is
stored at
admin.com.
Okay. So we'll just do
this.
This is where,
as I was reminded, kubeadm
likes to deposit its kube config.
So
Alright. And what command are you gonna use
to check for this control plan then?
What's your choice?
I just kinda start with nodes.
One second.
KubeCTL.
I do love a good permission denied editor.
I always Yeah. Right off the bat.
Okay. Was that I don't have permission to
KubeCTL
or to the git nodes.
That
is the binary Linux editor. Right? Yeah. Which
would just
Kevin
is watching with snacks.
Hopefully, you've got a beer there too, Kevin.
If not Where? Maybe next time.
Yeah. W H I C H.
Oh.
So I have root here.
One second. Let me just do
oh. I'll go to that.
Oh, yeah. That was actually really that's not
what I meant.
That is that is not what I meant.
And if you control c that, we're probably
gonna be stuck with a rather interesting terminal,
I think. Right? Oh.
Oh, was I not supposed to control c?
No. If you control c oh, no. You're
okay. You're okay. Normally, you get stuck in,
like, some sort of weird Unicode
binary blurb and you have to reset the
session, but I think you're alright.
How do I stop it?
It has stopped.
You know, c l s? I just typed
it.
No. I'm gonna reconnect.
I just refreshed the page. It'll be fine.
Alright.
Don't do that. That was dumb. Moving on.
Alright. So why was I getting permission denied?
I was going to actually check its permission,
its file permission. That's what I wanted to
do. Not Yeah. Cat may not be the
best command for that. Maybe try something else.
Yep.
I haven't rejoined yet. So
Alright. I'll check the permissions while you're rejoining.
Make myself useful.
Those look alright, actually.
So was it binary?
Was it a Linux final permission? Like, it
seems weird, especially being root that
I mean, unless it was owned by somebody
else, which it's owned by root,
and it has rewrite and execute.
Actually, could you try running kubectl
with, like, the full path and not like,
did he do some weird alias on kubectl,
which would hurt my feelings?
Nope. You're definitely getting permission denied.
But what could be causing that?
Any thoughts?
Keen observation from James in the the chat
there, I've gotta say.
That time stamp looks a little suspicious.
It does, doesn't it?
I've actually never run into this.
Alright. Let's let's talk about this. So
there I think there are few ways that
this could be achieved,
and then maybe we'll read chapter one in
a minute if I'm wrong. But we've checked
out the base permissions. Right? The alter permissions,
and those look
fine. We have the executable bit.
So the other thing that it could be
is potentially an attribute on the file that
doesn't allow it to be executed. Although, I'm
not sure
what attribute that would be.
No. That does not appear to be the
case.
So
what else could cause a permission denied would
be
potentially
that Russell has just compiled his own cube
control, which I think would be particularly devious.
But I don't put it past them, especially
considering our home directory here
has a good directory, doesn't it?
I'm I think my Internet's having trouble. One
second. Let me
let me check.
You're coming through just fine. I think that
okay.
I don't know. I'm, I'm breaking up.
You're okay on this side?
I can't hear anything that you're saying if
you guys are saying something.
Russell, can you hear me okay?
Yeah. I can hear you fine.
So can you hear me, Marek?
Okay. Yeah. So I heard you, Russell.
But you didn't hear me?
No?
I I cannot 01:00, two o'clock, three o'clock,
rock. No? You're not Oh, I got 03:00.
Yeah.
I'm not sure what that could be.
This is a part of my break.
Alright.
Well, Merrick works.
Don't we entertain ourselves with the
story?
So we go to chapter
one.
Alright. So
the I I couldn't hear you guys, but
I don't know if you can hear me.
But he could have
I think what you guys were saying is
his own KubeCTL. So I I think that
we could look at at the history on
that KubeCTL and if it's the actual right
one,
or we could read his story.
Well, if I mean, you've got a hypothesis.
I I'm assuming you can hear me, but
I don't know. We've got a hypothesis. Right?
We think potentially he swapped out the Kube
control paneling. I'm kind of inclined to believe
that he has. So I would suggest that
why don't we just reinstall
the Kube control binary with that?
Although Russell has said in the chat that
he only attacked the cluster.
That was about the dossing somebody. Not about.
Don't trip me up, Russell. This is hard
on him. Right.
Mark, you there?
Nope.
Alright.
Oh, he's away. Hopefully, hopefully he comes back.
Otherwise, I'm I'm fixing that cluster.
Let's see if we got a control plan.
So go on. Tell us, Russell, did you
recompile your own cube control?
I did indeed.
I compile I compiled it. I took a
look at it, did the modifications myself, looked
at the error messages. I was like, I
could just, yeah, I could just echo that
out. And then
I've
to to make it look more realistic, what
what I didn't do is change the data.
I should change the data. To make it
look more realistic, I I embedded the actual
cube control in it as a as a
resource, as in the binary sort of a
binary.
However, if you look at the the
hints, I kind of show you where it
is.
So I actually copied it before I put
my owner.
However, you you install the new ones up.
That's how easy it is.
Alright. So
I'm not gonna read this out loud for
everybody. I'll just leave it there for a
moment.
Yeah. I have to apologize to anybody that
likes Lord of the Rings. Yeah. I might
have I might have desecrated it. Sorry.
Alright. Okay. So we got a plot. We
got the hint, which I'm assuming is just
gonna say.
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
So when we run kget pods,
we have a Postgres,
but we don't have our clustered application.
So I'm gonna check for my deployment.
Oh, that's mean.
Now I have to get the YAML.
Alright. So all the automation for this looks
very clustered.
That's what I forgot to do. I forgot
to copy that one for you.
That's it.
Regular Kubernetes
deployment.
Raw.
Copy. Copy. Copy.
Oh, that's pretty much same thing. Oh, wrong
one.
Kip control
apply dash f.
Oh, sneaky, sneaky, sneaky.
Alright.
Let's check for the obvious things here.
Mutating
webhook configurations.
Alright.
Yeah. Marek has just reached the it says
his internet is having problems. So I'm just
gonna keep debugging the cluster for now and
hopefully Marek can join us again.
Okay. So cool effect. Like, I applied
the deployment YAML.
It appears
to work.
Oh, that is a very restricted view of
my cluster.
Maybe not actually because oh, yeah. Okay.
Because this is the rail cluster. Yeah. That's
deployment, isn't it? So, yeah, that's all it
should have. Yeah. I was just having a
moment.
Okay. So
where's my deployment?
So it gets accepted.
Okay.
Deployment.
Deployments.
Let's say I pop over one more of
these.
I'm gonna have to get a URL again
or copy it from here.
I'm not gonna have my export.
This is what I get for trying to
watch it. Okay. Wanna see if it flashes
in for a second.
Or if it's just not there at all.
Let's go back to our watch.
There we go. Okay.
So something it's getting created, but it's getting
deleted
pretty quickly. So I suspect that this could
be
the story of the rogue process.
I'll do a c m f in here.
That has Russell's signature on it.
You could be hiding something
on another node as well.
Looks alright.
That's that w w.
Okay. No weird triplet params.
Don't think so.
Cilium Teleport.
I assume that's okay.
I'll put it in the suspect list.
Control plan, etcd,
and then kernel processes.
Alright.
Do you mind if I ask you one
question before I go down some rabbit hole
here?
Fire away. No.
Is there is there a process running on
one of the worker nodes that I should
go be looking for, or am I just
is that we can done the wrong path?
Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. There is a process.
Alright. Guys, hear me? We can't hear you.
Welcome back.
I'm sorry. I think we're having pretty bad
snowstorms
in my area of the world, so I
don't know. Hopefully, that doesn't happen again.
Alright. I'm logging back in. You guys can
continue what you are, and I'll I'll catch
up. So
Okay. So
I'll tell you what I I did is
I ran a watch on the deployment and
recreated it because our deployment was missing and
it got deleted pretty quickly.
So
I'm assuming that there was a road process
running on a control plane, but I couldn't
see anything. And I asked Russell if I
should be checking the other nodes, and he
said,
yes.
So I Is there like a road container
running?
Well, if I can I'm gonna just see
if I can find something in PSE UX
at the moment. So you can join the
session on the worker one if you want
and start looking at that process list, or
you could jump on to worker two and
see if you could see anything. And then
I'll jump on to worker two. And then
I'll hop over once we find that.
It would be really speed it up.
You've already guessed it, jump speed it up.
You probably wanna jump on a worker two.
Alright.
Well, I'm gonna open a new session because
I don't wanna flash your IP address to
the world, Marek. So if
you Alright. Wanna join this one. I'll join
I'll join your session.
Alright.
What looks
suspicious?
There's a Chrome process running.
I wonder if we run
Chrome tab dash e.
No.
I should really put this to a pager
so we can both kinda follow along. Right?
So
I'm gonna assume he's not been sneaky enough
to name the binary starting with a a
left square bracket. Although, I think we'd still
see a forward slash at the start. So
I'm gonna trust the all left square brackets
are actual kernel processes.
I'm pretty sure I've tried that before.
So we got a comment there from Kevin.
There's an SSH process. There is it.
Is there?
That correct?
Yeah.
Is that
not what a normal SSHD command line looks
like?
I mean, when is that?
I I don't think that's suspicious. What what
do you think?
No? Absolutely not.
I don't know. I've never grabbed one, so
I wanna know. Yeah. I I I think
it's okay. I'm not I'm not terribly worried
about that.
We do have the cron demon and the
at demon, so I'm not ruling those out.
I'm not sure if I'd normally yeah. You
would see those normally, would you? I've just
got my suspicious head on that. Oh, wait.
Wait.
Wait. If it's if
question. When you were looking at it, was
it the control plane that was killing the
pod, or was the pod
just dying and then the control plane restarting
it over and over and over again?
Control plane.
So if it was the control plane, he'd
have to have an active connection to the
control plane. Right? I I did consider changing
the bank address on the control plane, but
then, you know, we still wanna deploy workloads
to the worker. I mean, we I mean,
we could we could just get rid of
worker two and have a one worker set
up. That's a good idea if that's what
the path you're thinking. But
Well, I was just trying to limit
try to understand how it might be working.
Because if it was, it would have to
be connecting through via some some
some connection. So then we could do, like,
a port scan.
Yeah. But I don't wanna let this sneaky
guy away with whatever this is.
It's your call, Marek. What do you wanna
do?
I'm just looking for a second.
Apparently, the chat are finding something called Rawk.
Did I met oh, there we go. I
did I don't see that. Where is it?
Where is it?
I don't see it either.
I'm looking.
Can we just grep for Rawk? Yeah.
Alright. Do you wanna take what's happening? Suspicious.
Yeah.
Alright. So let's see.
Alright. Good catch, audience.
Thank you. Can
I just add? I
the one part of my break that didn't
work because moving between kernels
was I was recompiling
PS.
So if that if I if they got
that working, you'd never have seen it.
So be thankful you're on Ubuntu.
It's like
work in PS clothing.
Alright. So
we found this.
What do we wanna do? Do we just
wanna kill it? And then
let's see.
How did he
I'm not sure if I'm connected. I'm I'm
trying to type. It's not typing.
Oh, there you go. Oh,
there we go. Sorry.
You think he's created a unit file for
it?
I don't know. I I thought I'd check.
Oh, I guess not.
Yeah. I say we just go We could
just kill it. Nine sucker that. Yeah.
It not typing again?
Let me do it.
I was trying to do just kill minus
nine on
the ID.
It is not coming back, so that's a
good sign.
That's why I was checking the like, if
you made a system file for it to
make it just come back.
Alright. Let's jump back onto our
control plane. I've got a curl command in
history that applies my deployment,
and it does appear to persist this team.
So I'll let you take over from here.
Alright.
We have nodes that look like they're running.
We have let's check our deployment.
So we can check the this is just
the actually, let's check all of it
just in case there's other things going on
in
so we have an ambassador failure. I think
that's actually normal, though. That is normal because
they haven't fixed it yet. So yeah. Just
ignore just ignore We do
have a core DNS issue.
This also, I think, is normal,
this VIP, but the core DNS is not.
So that's probably going to be an issue.
Let's see. Is there anything else at this
point?
Everything else looks
let's see.
So let's check out core DNS.
Yeah. Let's running the cube system.
Alright.
And we want
we'll just get the logs of this one.
Created seventy minutes ago.
Yeah. That's that's suspicious.
He probably changed the image on it.
So k. Logs.
Let's see.
I don't need the pod in there. I
Yeah. You could need that.
Invalid duration five.
Alright. Let's go ahead and check out
the core DNS deployment,
see what
if if there's anything that looks weird in
that. We're just going to call maybe a
dis
describe.
Actually, let's do get
the
alignment.
I mean, I would just jump straight in
there with kubectl get edit, but then I'm
a bit of a wildcard.
Alright. Let's do it. Let's edit.
It's not like we can make it any
more broken. Right? Oh, no. Don't don't say
that because I can. Absolutely.
I can't type.
Type it on a livestream is always the
the funniest thing ever.
I also I've just started like, in the
last month, I switched to the moon lander
keyboard,
and that's been an experience.
Yeah. You'll need to remove
deployment or deployment dot apps.
Yeah. I gave away my Midlander. I gave
up trying to type with it.
Oh, did you? Yeah. Alright.
Let's see. What does this deployment look like?
We have app, QBNS,
name, namespace. Where is the image file I'm
interested in this image?
Oh, wait.
Doesn't there have to be an image file?
Does it Yes. Go ahead. Normal?
Yeah. You need to scroll down a wee
bit further to the spec template spec.
Oh, okay. Sorry. I thought I
it cuts off halfway on my screen. I
Just resize the window, like, a millimeter and
it fixes the scroll. It's a teleport bug.
Oh.
Oh, okay. There we go.
It was all just okay. I got it.
Thanks. Alright. So let's see. Where is this
image?
So the image
looks okay.
Yeah. It does. What's failure threshold five?
I need to pull up maybe an a
standard one. I'm not sure if I see
anything that looks suspicious.
So I'll give you a
better context here. So this file might be
tampered with. I think the age of it
definitely means that it could be. However,
the there's a conflict map in the cube
system there. This one?
Oh, you wanna just check out the config
map?
Although, it does also look like he's passing
in his own core file. Good catch. I
never saw that. So where's that main main
point? Do wanna search for that?
It should be Okay. Towards the bottom of
this file.
So let's see. The mount point is right
here at Etsy
core DNS.
Okay. So if we go So
Then my teleport is doing that thing. Okay.
Oh, when you resize, it does it to
me.
Alright. Okay. I'll just leave it. I just
will realize that it's
okay.
So yeah. Oh, sorry. I won't resize it
again. You resize for the stream, and then
I won't touch it.
Alright. How do test your script right now?
Is that broken?
It's broken, but I can deal with it
if I just understand that I can scroll
down more. So Right. Okay. So we've got
a volume amount of the etcetera core DNS.
It's coming from the column fake volume. So
if we search for a config volume
And that's the core file. This is coming
from a config map called core DNS. So
let's do
I'm just gonna type since you've kinda got
half broken screen, but just
No. No. That's good. Just edit the yeah.
This looks like your error message. Right? Yeah.
The cancel five.
Maybe we just delete that line.
I think it should be a duration for
five s. Oh.
Okay.
Should that fix it?
We could we can check.
I don't know if you'll need to restart
it.
I think it was was it crash loop
back off, so it should restart anyways? So
we shouldn't have to delete it. I think
it's still called kubectin s. Right?
Yeah.
Damn it.
Well, we can get the logs and see
if that changed it. I don't know the
core DNS configuration that well.
Those those things are just all broken,
Russell.
He just
rolled his face on the keyboard in the
So if he's added these just to make
me think, oh, Adnan s will be okay,
but really it does nothing.
I was gonna say, I think we just
delete them. I can pull up a standard
core DNS file.
Let's go log again. What's the complain about
now?
I mean, should this be strength? I don't
know. I don't configure core DNS ever. I
I don't either. So, like It doesn't wanna
put the half limb duck one. Right? So
although it says string to I. Right? So
s t o I is string to integer.
So that probably should be a 30 in
that case.
Right. A time to live. Makes sense.
I'm gonna delete it one more time, and
if I if I see crash loop back
off or or failing, I'm gonna I'm
gonna be annoyed.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
So we
found a we found a logline in code
DNS.
Someone messed with the config. We have that
fixed. So
just get all in the default system here
and see what it looks like. Oh, let's
see. Everything looks to be running. Can we
access this now? We can. So we can
use the application
tab on Teleport
where I have exposed clustered.
And let's see.
Alright. We have the watch tab which is
version one. So now we have to try
and upgrade the application to v two.
Alright.
So
let's just run
an update on the let's just edit the
deployment. I don't know. Good call. Fine.
I've had comments on clusters where people call
me careless for the way that I work
with the cluster. So
I mean, let's be clear. I probably wouldn't
do this if this was a production cluster.
But,
yeah, that's a little bit different. So we're
gonna edit deployment of clustered.
A moment of truth for Russell.
Is this break gonna work?
Sorry. I'm working on a little tiny screen
here.
Okay. Let me do the version for you.
Oh, sorry. I'm I'm just making it worse
now.
I really need to think of our way
to search for that. There we go.
Yeah. That's yeah.
Thank you.
Alright.
Yeah. It looks like it's good.
Moment of truth processing. Try accessing it again.
Let's let's access it.
We have a DNS issue.
Success.
Alright. What
do you wanna look at?
So we have a DNS issue
with possibly our
database.
Upgrading it to version two is what caused
that.
One
second.
Let's see if we have anything that looks
wrong here.
So you know what? DNS is not my
greatest strong suit.
So
let's see. We could create a sidecar pod
and try to start pinging around, but that
seems like a lot of effort. Yeah.
Why don't we try to scrape why don't
you do get service and describe it and
see if we have endpoint as a starting
point, and then maybe we'll get Sounds good.
So we have the postgres service there.
So you'll want to describe it and see
if that is even working. Although, I suspect
it is from the first image.
Well, I was gonna say it worked the
first time which is the weird thing is
I would expect
the upgrade to the version number to not
have changed the Postgres back end. Right? Because
it's its own deployment as a stateful set.
Sure. Shall we exec end to the cluster
pod and do some debugging?
If you got I don't know of anything
else to like,
I don't know of another way. So I
mean, he could've
fart the cluster repository,
rebuilt his own cluster damage, and injected that
into the cluster.
But
He went through I I don't think Russell
would do that.
That's amazing if you did that. Hats off.
So,
yeah, there's a few things I'm curious about.
I I think we should get inside that
pod.
Which one? The the clustered? Yeah. Yeah.
I I wanna run some DNS commands and
and see if we can actually
Yeah. If we can get an IP address.
Go for it. Alright. Okay. It's not typing
for me again. I'm trying to just do
the exact.
I think sometimes when I highlight it, it
gets weird.
Alright. So we got
did I not leave myself? That's
I I I can't leave a shell on
these images. Maybe these aren't my images after
all.
Okay.
But he would've had to upload it to
your like, he would've it it's pulling from
a public repository. Right? He can't have screwed
with that image.
Wait. There are few ways to screw with
that image.
Describe the the
the
deployment again.
It's coming from your repository unless we hacked
your repository.
Look at the image ID.
Oh,
okay.
So
what we need to do
is
just nuke the local image. Right?
So what's the code policy on this?
Just set it to always.
Yeah. Let's do edit
deployment
clustered.
Pro policy.
That is on always. Okay.
He's
he's injected the image another way. I can
only think of one way. I don't wanna
jump to conclusions just yet.
We've got seven Okay.
Let's see.
How would you inject your image? I mean,
like, you can hijack your DNS so that
it's not going there. That would be one
way. I would hope it failed the TLS
negotiation.
Yeah. It could've So that's fucked with container
d.
To pull from, like, a local repository first?
Yeah. Container d has, like, this alias support
where you can tell it to you know,
instead of going to Docker Hub, go to
the public GCR or something like that. I've
never updated that. Let's check that out. I
don't know where that is. So So what
worker
is this on?
This is
Worker two. Alright.
Yeah.
There we go. Worker two.
So
I'm pretty sure there's a dump config on
container d.
Oh,
I just ran another container d.
It's not respecting my signal.
Alright. Let's get another one.
Alright. New session on worker two? Yeah. Alright.
So
let's run PS.
Grap
container d.
So
that's my rogue process. So I guess I
can kill that.
So if
let's
see.
It's not showing me. I'm sure I told
it to show me everything.
Oh, wait. I put one too many w's.
That doesn't help. Okay.
Container
d help.
Oh, now I've got a dodgy session.
Config
help
dump.
Okay. So there is he's not doing this
to the container d. I don't think.
There was no admission controllers,
at least dynamic ones.
We then checked the control plane for static
admission controllers, but then I'm not even sure
if there is one that substitutes the images.
Oh, yeah. Just
it would have to also be pretty sophisticated
because it had to pick up that it
was version two that it needed to substitute
for because version one worked. I guess maybe
he just left version one working,
and we were on a bad container anyways.
Never mind.
That falls apart. Maybe he can pound container
d?
Wait. Wait. Let's go back to his story.
Yeah.
Chapter should we be looking at? Chapter four.
Oh, this is this is the the final
break.
Take the
And so there's that trust issue, which is
so I think we are.
Oh. Maybe he has done some DNS trickery,
but he's put it on an unsecure mode
of some sort. Right? Wait. What about what
about network policy?
To redirect traffic?
Yeah.
Maybe. I I I I've not heard of
it used in that way, but I'm not
gonna write it off.
I
I don't know.
I was just thinking
possibly
on
I I
I'm not Okay. Seeing anything.
I don't think that I mean, could this
be just be as hacky as
post?
No.
Alright. We've got two and a half minutes.
Do we wanna look at the hand?
Yeah. Let's look at the hand.
I don't
I think that's just telling us that we
can't trust the image, which we know.
Yeah.
So there's a good comment there from our
loop in the chat saying that we should
check for the DNS policy on our deployment,
which is a really good idea.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
Edit deployment.
There's too many ways to break a Kubernetes.
I will say this is
incredibly mean what I've done.
Alright. This is
a clustered first policy, which
I think is all right.
Now if he was gonna do it with
the cluster DNS, we would be able to
see it in
here.
And there's nothing there.
Oh, I hate you so much, Russell.
Yeah. That's the
only thing I wanted for this.
Because it is so mean. Do you wanna
just talk through how it could be done
instead of you going having a look at
things and wasting time?
I don't waste the time. I'm fixing a
cluster. Okay. Are are we close?
Are we close?
You've you've obviously found the fact that I'm
changing the image. It's just how how does
an image get onto a pod?
Not pod. A node, I guess.
Oh,
can we it it's the can we check
the kube config or the kubelet config?
Or am I completely off in checking that?
Okay. Superbots.
Superbots. Superbots.
Super
warm?
Okay.
Because the cubelet is the one that's going
to be responsible for telling the OCI to
I think it tells container d to pull
the image.
He's not he's not modified to cluster DNS,
which I thought
So
if you were there, I would have said
hot.
And I but at a time and and
just what I've done is, like, really, really
mean.
You know, it's that way I'd go on
Uh-huh. We we noticed go. Yeah.
Yeah. It wasn't just cube CTL that I
built.
Did did you actually compare that Kubler?
Yes.
Specifically targeting
clustered v two.
I you you've you've found the the trick
soup like, really, really quickly. So if you
look at your actual page, it'll give you
a hint in a meta tag.
I was hoping you could go have a
look at the oh, it's broke DNS again
somehow. So if you view the source,
that's not actually
obviously, you know it's not actually your container.
You compiled half of Kubernetes for this. You
realize? Pretty much. And on on the unbundling
system because I could do it on my
my laptop,
copied it over, and it didn't work. This
is like I'm on a different kernel version.
Yeah.
And, again, I I I did a backup,
but, like, it's
as I said, it was incredibly mean what
I did. Close all tabs. Russell is gone.
We yep. Bye bye. Russell.
Bye. Russell, I don't even want you I
don't even want you to touch my cluster
because, like, I didn't do
anything
half as good. That was fantastic. No. That
was me. No. No. I think yeah. I
I I agree with David. That was me.
Yeah.
That that was that was me. More
for David than for you. That
was good.
I will never try you know what? Honestly,
it's probably a good
moral of the story is don't trust your
binaries.
Well, that's one of those things. You know,
I was talking on the Discord about how
I'd really love, like, a a cluster check
command. And one of the things we would
have to do is just do those checks
on all of the compiled binaries for the
first.
Because you all have after the first
binary, we should have just replaced all the
binaries. Just been like, no. We're done. Well,
yeah, we had to hand. We've seen the
Go folder. Like, we should have we should
have known.
I thought he would've stopped the cube control.
Alright. Yeah. Good break, Russell. That was that
was good fun.
And I could Hopefully, yeah. I I learned
that the how sort of, like,
parts get deployed on. I was like, I
kind of think I know what is going
on, but, it goes by the API server
into the Kubelet. Kubelet tells container d, and
I was like, Kubelet, I can attack it
down and change it before it gets to
container d. It's like, I learned a little
bit about how the overall ecosystem works from
it. Yeah. I knew you wouldn't go down
a container d route in my head because
I'm like, we've seen that a couple of
times now in clusters. I didn't think you
would go down that because you'd know how
it would look.
But to compare it on Kubelet was particularly
harsh.
Good job.
It's
easier than you think. You can get the
source code from GitHub for the actual release.
And it's all the make files set in
everything good for you. So you can get
it done within, like, a few minutes.
Well, now
the boot is on the other foot.
Yep.
Now I'm
gonna warn you, Russell. One of these breaks
is unintentional.
I accidentally broke a teleport,
and one of the nodes just never came
back.
And I never touched that node. So we're
gonna have to debug that one together.
So
fair warning on that one.
Alright. I have opened the session on control
player one for the cluster.
Russell, if you could please join start exporting
your KubeConfig.
Your forty five minutes start in forty five
minutes. Hang on a minute. So where's the
sessions at? I can't see it on the
screen. And then active session. Activity. Ah, sorry.
Oh, nervous now.
Oh, you're in. Awesome.
Yep.
Zero trust. Yep. That's that's the only way
this is.
Right. So
oh, yeah. Just Russell, just do me a
favor and resize your screen a bunch to
yeah. I've heard that he likes that.
Apparently, it's just because Oh, it's okay. Xterm
GS
doesn't like it when the two terminals are
different sizes, and it tries to accommodate it.
I'm gonna have to, like, set out a
size of my window and then ask everybody
to resize their window to be exactly the
same number of pixels.
Or we could always use the terminal CLI,
I guess.
If I do this again, I think I'll
try to set up the terminal CLI. I
think that would just be a better experience.
Yeah. The CLI does work well.
Alright. We have a working control plan to
not ready worker node.
So one of them is unintentionally broken, and
one of them is actually broken. Is that
what we're saying?
Yes. Yes.
And he's not telling you which.
Nope. That's fair enough. That's fair enough.
Actually,
I made a I I didn't tell you
this. There's a setup file that would have
alias that out for you.
So scheduler
is
a real break.
Postgres is down.
Ambassador,
I'm assuming, is just Yep. Some Collateral damage.
Yep. Okay. Cool. Same with keep that.
Right. Okay.
Right. So
why would
the notes
notes be offline.
What is it called?
K twenty dash clavin dash worker dash one.
I can copy and paste it if you
want.
Alright. Nope. It's not on it.
Whoops.
Right there, brother.
Did you do it? I did do it.
As always, there's a road key, I think,
from us typing over each other. So just
knock that off the end.
CPU.
Qubel stop posting status.
Oh, where'd you say that?
If you scroll up to the the event
tags.
Ah, yeah. Okay. That makes right.
My screen's only partially full.
So if I re
no. Even the browser screen's just, like, squished.
It's, like, weird. Yeah. That's that. Sorry.
What are those weird teleport bugs? I didn't
understand what you're talking about before when you're
saying, like, resize the screen and all that.
What size is your monitor?
Four k.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
Oh, I think we're we're gonna be too
far apart to get it close.
No. It's alright. I can deal with this.
I'll just resize my window.
Oh, no. I can't. I'll just leave it
as it is. You can resize your window,
and then I'll resize mine, and maybe it'll
magically work. There's a there is, like, a
certain number of times you can do it,
and it will start working.
Right.
You just fix yours now. I'll leave mine
as it is.
Are you good?
Yeah. I think so. Right. Alright. Don't touch
anything except
maybe type in kubectro command.
Alright. So do you wanna jump on to
the workers and check the kubelet out?
I'm still trying to see the message that
says the kubelet is down. I can't see
that in my
It's underneath
lease, and then there's conditions.
I don't know if you got it on
your screen. Uh-huh.
These ones.
Ah. Oh, yeah. Okay. I'm blind.
Right. Okay. So we need to go on
to
Yes. Go work one first.
Alright. Session started.
Give my Internet a minute.
Alright.
Alright. There's definitely some errors there.
Ever get a node,
worker one not found.
Yet the key, but it's up and running.
What's the command to find out the is
it?
So it's not
What do you see?
No. There's I think I remember from one
of the one of the one of your
shows.
If you change the name of the host
and then restart Cuba and then change it
back, it
messes up with Cuba.
I wonder if he's done that.
So you want to restart the Cuba again?
No. I'll look first.
Oh.
Yeah. You've
have you resized again?
No.
I've lost a lot of text. I've now
down to, like, a quarter of what I
was before.
Welcome
to my pain.
And then, like, it will stop letting me
type for a little while because I think
it puts the cursor somewhere.
I don't know.
I was having troubles.
I'm using the terminal next time I do
this.
So
it is timing out,
waiting for something.
So that
is that the IP of the
API or machine to the API server?
That 91.
Let's have a look. Is it 91?
Yeah.
That is the
BGP address
of our control plane.
So it looks like he's blocking.
So I'm gonna ask Barack a question because
I don't want us to go down a
rabbit hole here.
Is this intentional,
Marek, or is this
not intentional?
You're muted.
You're still muted.
The guest has muted himself.
Nope. He's just hit the hang up button.
Well, I deserve that for the the Kubelet,
so fair enough. Alright.
So
See, because if this is not intentional,
I would get us out of it very
quickly because it could just be that KubeBlep
is acting up and not advertising our address
anymore.
But if it is intentional, then it's gonna
be some networking thing that we have to
start debugging. So you could try curling HTTPS
on the IP address and see what you
get back. I'd say that's a good or
a ping. Yeah.
The space at the start.
It's a double top. Double top.
Yeah. There's no ICMP
ping here, so maybe it isn't functional.
Can I control c? Will just break everything.
No. You control c. Hey. Welcome back, Mark.
I
heard I'm gonna ask Mark a question, and
then everything
died.
Okay.
Is this intentional break, or should I quickly
get around this BGP issue?
Wait. What's the issue?
Worker one
can't reach the control plane on this BGP
IP.
Yeah. This is the unintentional break. Okay. So
that's alright. I think that's because kubect is
broken. So I am gonna quickly fix this.
We have the other IP address here.
That's why I warned you that it was
unintentional.
Yeah. That's alright.
F m kiplet.
What IP address is this using?
Yeah. Okay.
Now let's just swap this over.
And this might actually be affecting the other
node as well. Yeah.
Was other breaks to it though. So yeah.
Yeah. I think could fit this had a
little bit of a moment itself.
Sorry about that. I I think I helped
it along in its issue.
Yeah.
I gave it a little kick in the
pants.
So if you guys wanna know the lesson,
the moral of the story here is do
not
restart your clustered
control plane
an hour before the cluster goes live because
Annoyingly, I'm gonna have to fake the cube
clip because we don't have the IP address
at our control plane.
So it's I'm super sorry, Russell.
That's alright.
Alright. Let's get this fixed.
After what I did with that cube, but
yeah. Just just don't apologize to me.
Alright.
Come here, cube that. What is your problem?
After what you did with a cubelet, I
have a ton of respect for you. So
that was awesome.
I'm not sure what David thinks that. Thank
you.
I mean, I think he made his feelings
very clear.
Am I disconnected? Are you
I'm still here. He's he's trying not he's
trying not to swear.
I'm not trying not to swear.
I'm pretty sure this is a bug that
KubePap introduced recently.
Yeah. But the bank address.
And I did look for 221
in here and then find it.
So interestingly enough, this bug actually
was always here. It just caused it not
to come back okay.
The cube bit was always complaining about this
bind address because I actually wasted about an
hour and a half of my time digging
into this.
Yeah. There's a file you can pass.
Yeah. I've never used CubeBit before, though. There
we go.
What we need is this.
And then as we modify our daemon stack,
and I'll just add this flag very, very
quickly.
So why does this not happen on the
other cluster?
Did you restart the control plane?
No.
So
I bet you his KubeVit is
in a bad state. The cluster just isn't
broken until you restart it.
Right.
Alright.
That should fix it.
We should see
pending.
Oh, yeah. Okay. So
you're gonna have to fix the schedule and
I'll wrestle.
So can I go back onto the notes?
Or I'll I'll at the schedule first, but
then are the notes gonna be working now?
Not until we get oh, yes. Okay. So
I I can just cheat and schedule the
cube map daemon set if you want.
Although, that shouldn't actually go through a scheduler.
Right?
I thought you're
asking me. I don't know.
I don't use keep it.
Well, wait. How is it being run? Is
it run as a deployment, or is it
run as a It's a daemon set.
If it's a daemon set, then yeah. But
it has no node.
And we need a That's interesting.
Alright. Let's cheat.
Oh, we can't cheat because he was there.
Alright. Let's fix the schedule, Russell.
Okay.
Back to me. Alright. So
I can't use my shot because it's gonna
Namespace.
Thank you.
See, I'm not that good at Kubernetes, really.
I'm just good at breaking things.
I'm not good at anything.
If you're also good at breaking things.
Oh, okay.
But we failed container.
Yeah. I think you're gonna have to get
the logs with that pod.
Okay.
Is my greatest letdown.
This break
was supposed to rival
Russell's,
but
didn't.
Namespace.
Yeah.
Have you just tried the tool QB? It's
really cool for switching context to namespace.
Oh, look. Have a scheduler. I have a
scheduler. I have a scheduler.
I don't think that's what
it normally puts out, so I'm assuming that
the
somebody has gone and changed
the static manifest.
So I have a trick
if he's done this on the
if it works. Let me try and find
it.
Well, it might have ripped. So
We are always ripped on custard.
You're gonna use the VIM backup?
Yeah.
I
I I left the backup.
I'm never that mean. If I change a
if I change a file,
it's back in here. Save that. It's all
good.
Thank you.
So he's changed the scheduler. He has edited
some things, which I assume
I'm not sure if we can get back
to that.
Right. So
Yeah. Three and four look pretty ominous.
Yeah.
So the real one is in manifest.
The one in
just Kubernetes is
I'm assuming is the backup. So we're gonna
have a look at the manifest first. That's
its authentication
to the cluster. That is KubeConfig.
Yep.
Shetler.
Oh, Shetler.conf.
Yep.
Not YAML.
Yeah. Remember, you're only seeing what's in BIM.
Alright. Let's go look at the static manifest,
and we'll take it from there.
Alright. So,
hopefully, it's going straight to that. Also, I
believe if you use g and semicolon
or g and comma, you can go to
all of the edits. So let's have a
look at that.
Well, there's something there that's
interesting.
Yeah.
Yep. So
command
and the image have been changed.
So I am not sure. So
I don't know what the actual
real ones are gonna be. I think the
image is GCH.
Is it Google?
Yeah. I think I can take that off
the top of my head. No. Fair enough.
Thank you.
I
can't spell scheduler, but scheduler
one point So there's also a backup file
in dot backup if you just want that
one.
You guys found both things. So Alright. Okay.
Right. Okay.
So the actual real shame of this, Russell,
is that I wrote my own scheduler,
and it was supposed to run.
Why is everybody being so harsh?
It
actually runs on my my kind cluster,
but I didn't get its credentials correct. And
then I kinda broke my cluster, so I
didn't have enough time to debug it. But
it all it did was print out one
does not simply run a pod
Nice.
Whenever you tried to schedule something. So Well,
you've not been that nice with your backup.
Because you forgot to
no. That is right. Oh, if I got
that right, cool. Okay. Cool.
I was gonna say I'm kind with my
backups. Anytime I change a manifest file, I
make a backup so that Well, it's because
the deaf didn't show the image, but it's
because I forgot I fixed the image and
then did the the
alright. Even got the version right? That's that's
impressive.
Hey. These are
hand rolled well, fully automated clusters, but I
put a lot of stuff into these clusters.
And then QVAP comes along and
makes my list of all the visitors.
Can't see the scheduler. That just means the
kubelet's restarted. It takes ten, twenty seconds.
Okay. Probably saying that maybe pulling an image
right now because the pull policy was always,
I believe.
Fair enough.
So, yeah, sounds like you've run into the
same problems I did, Mark, because I was
developing my
evil
on a kind cluster as well. And when
I moved it over, nothing worked properly.
Yeah. I just made the grave mistake of
restarting my control plane, and then nothing worked.
And so I didn't have time to debug
it. So
sorry about that. It was supposed to be
a little bit more devious, just a little
bit.
Come on, scheduler.
You know what? I don't know why, but
I found the scheduler doesn't come back until
you restart the cubelet.
I finally cut it along a wee bit.
There we go.
Cool. It
should. Anytime you update the static pod manifest,
it should. But for some reason,
it wasn't.
Okay. It's now rescheduling everything that needs to
reschedule. So that's good. Although my cue put
fix doesn't work.
So we just give up on. That's fine.
Oh, you're going you're gonna try and fix
it? There's also an environment variable we can
pass them to change that port.
Okay.
There. No. That's the flag.
I have try to flag again. I'm sure
there's an environment variable though.
I'll make one more change to it and
we'll see if we can get by with
that.
Okay.
What's wrong with that?
Just because that's what it shows as the
default minus the port change that we need
to make.
I'll call on two.
Alright. We'll see if that helps.
Off you go.
Right. So
you've sorry.
Fixed the
worker nodes. So if I why is it
not typing?
Okay.
Yeah. I had the same problem. Why isn't
it typing?
Sometimes it doesn't.
Oh, both of the work are not gonna
ask this question.
Uh-huh.
Are both of the working nodes
now intentionally broken, or is one of them
still unintentionally
broken?
I mean,
there are
minor
breaks
on the nodes.
Yes.
I
don't think I'm gonna see anything from
oh, let's just do it anyway.
I described the pod.
That's not how you do that.
Copy and paste isn't very
friendly for
I was just using the mouse. The mouse
worked pretty well, which, I mean, is a
context switch from your keyboard. But
So I think
what happened? Oh. I resized.
Know I know we're gonna get used to
that.
I gotta open another session quickly and fix.
I'll pop that over here so it doesn't
but I'll get cube bit working
while you debug.
Okay.
Really sorry about the cube bit.
That's not your fault. That is Dan Federan's
fault. Dan.
I I do believe
you warned us that restarting the nodes would
take a long time, and you meant they
take a long time.
They do. Yeah.
So those tolerations,
are they
they look a bit dodgy, but I'm not
sure if that's always there or not.
Not ready, no execute, and unreachable, no execute.
Is that just
the norm?
Okay. Sorry. I'm back with you now. So
we're looking we're looking at
Can you see the highlight?
No. I don't see it. That would be
a cool feature though, but sadly not though.
Yeah. Obviously, it's yeah. Okay. So we got
zero nodes are available. One node has a
tint.
So just under the tolerations,
are they normal?
It's pretty normal for a node to have
a toleration that the node has to be
ready to run on it. Right. So that
so what that's saying is it's not ready.
If it's not ready or unreachable,
yeah, don't try execute don't try schedule to
it.
Okay. Right. And it's no execute on a
not ready or unreachable mode. Mhmm. CubeBit is
happy again. I would expect our notes to
be happy again very, very soon.
I I would expect them to be happier.
But
the BGP issue is not a thing anymore.
So
if you can So I can go on
to worker one, can I?
We have a session open on worker one.
Yep. You can pop over there.
K. Go. Hello. There we go.
Oh, that's because you were typing as well.
Oh, okay.
What was I doing last? Yeah. Apparently, spelled
Prometheus wrong in the flag. Thanks to James
for pointing that out.
I got it fixed.
So if you restart that, I could I
think that'll be okay.
Okay.
Assuming I set the IP address back in
their config, which I'm pretty confident I did.
Yeah. That's a good kubelet.
That's a bad kubelet.
Did I not change the IP address back?
Well, I'm sorry.
That just makes me a terrible, terrible person.
Should be 8191.
Is it using 8191?
No.
Alright. I thought I was confident I changed
that back.
Oops. Sorry. I was just gonna run a
journal.
Alright. I'll step back and let you. I
just wanna make sure that I'm not tripping
you up anymore than I already am.
Okay. So this isn't the BGP. This isn't
TLS. This is now just a broken node
from, I believe.
So
Right.
Felt like a node node in four.
Keep it container runtime network not ready. Not
ready. Network plug in not ready. Network plug
in returns error. CNI plug in not initialized.
So
what has it done to the network?
Do you know how the CNI
works?
No. I've never touched that to try and
break it for you yet.
Alright.
And so what happens I I was just
checking on a control plan there to see
if we had our Cilium
pods on all the nodes, which appears that
we do.
They have an a container that actually downloads
binaries to each node,
which I suspect could have been tampered with
and may maybe the binaries removed,
which would cause that error.
Say that again, sorry. Missed that. So we
have an error in our kubelet logs. Container
runtime network not ready, network ready false, network
plugins returned an error, c and I plugin
not initialized.
I can't remember where they download to. I
thought it was maybe slash c and I.
But if we jump to the control plane
node for a moment
and if we edit the daemon set.
Right. I'm on that. Yeah. Alright.
So Liam,
There's Emmet containers.
Not what I expected to see,
but doesn't mean it's wrong.
Is that they download
the binaries to the machine,
OpsCNI, okay. So if we take a look
in here,
those all look okay.
So Okay. That idea is
dumped.
So can I have a look,
which
one am I on?
Why can I see
inside what's to do VIM
in my
Alright? In the control. I'm on the control
plan. I can I'm inside VIM. I've kinda
stepped out of that. Yep.
Alright.
So what are the
And there's comment on the chat there from
Cook Jan saying, what do the logs from
Solium say?
Yeah. I'd be curious about that too.
That's not the.
Just pick any of the non operator sodium.
Okay.
Useful.
Will that be the same for all of
them? Yeah. I feel it will be too.
Just have a look at this one.
I
feel like we wanna look at that demon
set again,
potentially.
Oh, what's the
So this was another
of the cilium. So let's just check that
I'm
not going crazy.
So I looked at this cilium, which had
a restart,
And that's what the logs are from this
one.
I I
yeah.
Shall we take a look? Chip in if
you want. Well, we've got hints in the
in the story, do we?
Are they on the root fail system?
No. You'd be No. There is your setup
script.
Yep.
But I don't wanna I don't wanna be
I just want to
I I'll just say there is no more
image shenanigans.
You can trust every other image that you
find so that we don't have to go
down that rabbit hole with literally every image.
You don't have to think that I hijacked
Cilium image and compiled it. But you have
broken Cilium. Right?
I have broken something that has broken Cilium.
Yes. Alright.
On the worker nodes.
Possibly. Yeah.
Cilium won't be working possibly. Yes.
Yeah.
Okay. So
I don't know. So we might have to
know whether or not it would help us.
Neither. What the problem is. Do I?
Alright. So what would what would break So
Liam? Right? So
we don't get any logs from the pod.
So we need to just work this out.
The binaries do exist in.
So I'm thinking, like,
it's probably something
I think, outside of Kubernetes that's network based,
where it can't be taking the
network interface down because of a bit of
talk to it. I believe that's right, isn't
it? Mhmm. Even
so it shares the same IP. So
it could either be a firewall or IP
tables.
Let's take a look.
Alright. So are we
on worker one?
We are. I've ran a list on IP
tables.
I mean, we could just yolo this right
into a flush
and see
it gets things kicking over again.
So gone. If there was an IP table
rule,
it no longer exists.
What else can we Will
that break Cilium though or will Cilium
inject its rules back in?
Cilium will just add the rules back in.
Okay.
Now we're getting a connection timeout and our
IP here.
No. Because it is an IP, it can't
be a host file entry. You can't override
I don't think you can override IPs to
IPs.
I really hope this isn't the BGP thing
again. And that's just something
just intentional, Mark. Just wanna check.
Because the BGP looks okay.
In fact, you can't bang out you can't
ping a BGP address. I'm just being really
silly.
Okay. Networking thing.
Has back any rules? No. Should we rotate
the pods?
It's
yeah. Like I guess so. Like, it's it's
always been yeah. Let's
Delete everything and the world.
Bye bye. Bye bye. Bye bye. Bye bye.
Alright.
I get a bit happy when I delete
things.
Alright. Those are terminating.
We've got one up, but not quite ready.
Alright. One ready, one up.
No rules yet.
Makes that we win for that node.
Let's check.
Grip.
This one's still terminating.
You want, well you want a control plug,
mate.
Yeah. It's not I mean, we could maybe
try and speed that along, but perhaps that's
part of the brick.
I'm not feeling it running.
So we don't have currently, we don't have
Celium working on our node
and it's not terminating.
I don't see a process.
So this must be a Kubernetes thing. Right?
So
if the node
if the node was down,
Kubernetes wouldn't be able reschedule anything, would it?
I can't delete it because yeah. Of course.
I forgot about that. So the it's never
gonna terminate because it's not I can't reach
the kubelet.
We could try restarting the kubelet now that
we flushed all those rules.
Let's see if we got a happier kubelet.
But I think there's an underlying problem that's
gonna stop the kubelet from talking to
the API server.
I think you're right.
I just I just don't know enough now.
Like, this this is where we start to
reach my limit of Linux.
I don't know anything about firewalls and for
a lot. So
Alright. Do want me to give a hint?
Yes,
please. Now I was kind of ex
I was kind of expecting the flush of
the IP tables to fix it because I
just did a UFW
rule rule
to drop all communication from the server.
No. It's UFW, but
But UFW just sets up
IP table rules. Right?
Now I don't know if it just reset
it, but it didn't look like it reupdated
the IP table. So I don't know.
Is the IP table flush should have w
now. Yeah.
Yeah. The the IP table flush should have
fixed it because, again, UFW is just a
front end for the IP tables.
So
So this this probably has my BGP thing
again.
This is probably your b b I was
gonna say, you actually did fix
the thing I broke because I just
dropped the port
that the cubelet communicates on.
Okay.
So that was
Has that been done on worker two as
well?
No. I didn't repeat. I don't I don't
do repeat
this time. Alright. So is worker two down
intentionally,
or is that a BGP problem as well?
Probably both.
Ah, okay. Right. So
there is a definite break on worker two
as well.
The break on worker two is more subtle.
I would actually expect the node to show
available,
just not function properly.
Okay. I am gonna very quickly delete
QPub control plan.
Fair mail is hard. You know?
It's hard. It's it's very, very big.
I should save that curl command.
Just so I'm gonna try restarting the kubel
one more time.
Okay.
Why?
I I don't think ship that is doing
what it's supposed to be doing, which is
really frustrating because that's kind of
ruined any chances we have of getting this
to work.
Yeah. I'm sorry, guys.
That is my my I p g p
address. Right?
The
8191.
Yeah.
and I've not messed up, have I?
No.
Damn. You keep that.
So
So with this, it's going to be really
hard to actually debug the other thing. So
I can either just step you through them
since we're low on time. Well, with any
of your breaks, I've actually stopped Kubelet from
being able to advertise.
No. No. I specifically with, like I I
did very targeted. So, like, with my firewall,
I dropped the Kubelet port, not anything else.
I didn't drop all communication ports because that
would, like, break SSH and things like that.
So they were very targeted towards the cubelet.
So, no, it wouldn't have broken it.
So should we try
oh, we've only got a minute left. I
was gonna say, should we go on to
the
worker worker two? Because that that hasn't had
its IP tables pushed yet or This cilium
stopped.
Yeah. This is where it's gonna be very
hard to solve the other issues. They're not
hard. They're just
if this isn't working, then the other issues
aren't seen.
Okay. I'm
gonna run out I'm gonna run out of
time then, I guess, but I I I
don't mind going on a little bit further
if you want, but
if you wanna explain it then. Yeah. Why
don't you walk us through it, Marek?
Okay. Yeah. I I right now, don't think
we can curl and speak to that BGP
address, which makes me think that it's not
being advertised,
and we're just
we're dead in the war at that rate.
So on node one, I just dropped all
communication on the cubelet port
so that Kubelet wouldn't be able to communicate
anymore.
That's
all I did there. And then on the
second node, the only thing I did was
I
took
the
kube config and turned its quality of service
down so it could only make one request
per second,
which means that
when you pull pods and stuff, it actually
communicates more than that. And it makes a
funny error because, like, the cubelets working and
communicating,
it's just doing it really, really slowly and
it causes weird errors. I thought that would
be fun, but we never got to that.
So
But unless it said in the logs rate
limited or something, I would never have found
that.
Did you use that? Can Was the traffic
control you used or something else to change
the quality of service?
I used Go's built in. You Go has
a built in rate limiter, so I use
that.
That that will do it. So it was
anyways, I was pretty happy with that one.
And then the very last thing that I
did is I went into the deployment
and
for your your Postgres database,
and I dropped all
capabilities
on the container, which it has to access
the file system and the network and stuff.
So it had no capability, so the database
would never run
because it didn't have it didn't have the
permissions too. So that was the last last
thing.
Well, damn, we both
I mean,
I know we got a recompiled kubelet and
a recompiled kubectl, but messing with networking is
just as evil. Well,
I
Russell, I
I appreciate your cluster. That was good.
Thank you very much. I was absolutely flummoxed
by yours. Yeah.
As I said, I would not have got
that quality of service thing. Well, I set
you up for failure with this broken BGP,
looks like. So Oh, yeah. Yeah. I'm definitely
gonna blame you. I'm definitely blaming you.
Alright. Well, thank you both for joining me.
Those are some really good breaks on both
sides there. Really cool. And I hope that
we were able to share some knowledge with
the audience of how to potentially debug some
stuff. And I will make sure that we
have some properly
working clusters before our next session.
All right. I wanna say thank you to
Teleport and Equinix Medal again. Thank you to
Russell. Thank you to Merrick. I hope you
all have a wonderful evening. Clustard is not
back next week, unfortunately, but we are back
the following week.
So I will see you all then. Yes.
Alright. Have a a great day. I'll speak
to you all soon. Thanks. Bye.
Bye.